mais sa chaire ben ali
à hawaï
les voix de thomas arthur ou encore
linda shelby n'ont plus de secret pour
ces lycéens aujourd'hui ce sont eux qui
doublent les personnages de la célèbre
série picchi blenders une initiative de
leur professeur d'anglais et du
réalisateur yvelinois benjamin pas lié
maintenant toutes les nouvelles
générations sont très passionnés par ce
genre de choses avec tous les réseaux
sociaux qui existent ils pas se mettre
en scène facilement donc quand on leur
propose de se mettre en scène derrière
un micro devant une caméra ils sont très
contents ils voient encore plus
l'importance de l'oral finalement
avoir la correction de la prononciation
de l'intonation aussi qui est très très
importante donc je trouve que c'est
encore plus concret et motivant pour le
travail de la langue deux micros un
enregistreur et une bande rythmo projeté
sur le tableau cette salle de classe
prend le temps d'un instant les allures
d'une salle d'enregistrement
une expérience qui change des cours
habituels ça change de l'ordinaire et ça
permet d' un peu changé sa voix ça
permet de vivre d'autres personnages
c'est clairement la meilleure façon
d'apprendre une façon ludique et à la
fois qui vraiment nous pousse à
travailler parce qu'on est obligés de
s'entraîner pour la prononciation et
franchement et en plus on prend vraiment
là un accent anglais britannique
véritable ce qui compte c'est d'être
intéressés et à partir du moment où le
professeur est capable de capter
l'attention des élèves ça apporte
beaucoup et je pense que là dessus
travailler différemment amener des
nouvelles pédagogies permet
effectivement de pouvoir promouvoir
l'anglais l'occasion aussi de faire
connaître le travail de comédien de
doublage une profession encore méconnu
qui n'est pourtant pas dénué de
complexité ce qui est compliqué c'est
déjà la technique vocale donc la bande
rythmo à suivre qui peut être très
rapide à certains moments selon le
rythme du jeu de voix du personnage à
l'écran et puis la transformation de la
voix aussi on le voit pas trop c'est
quand même à des gens derrière l'écran
mais c'est vrai que c'est assez
compliqué au quotidien de faire ça et il
faut avoir un sacré talent je pense pour
le chat quand on voit le travail c'est
quelque chose surtout que là on a fait
des scènes de quelques minutes et quand
on se dit qu'il ya plusieurs films et où
c'est quand on travaille des ateliers
qui porteront leurs fruits à la fin de
l'année le grand oral du baccalauréat
est prévue du lundi 20 juin au vendredi
21 juillet 2022